so a few weeks ago I told you about the
Trump administration giving a huge
contract for n95 masks to a company with
no employees whose parent company
recently filed for bankruptcy and we
have another one of these stories we've
now learned about the Trump
administration giving a contract worth
anywhere from three hundred and fifty
four million potentially up to eight
hundred and twelve million dollars to a
tiny Virginia company that has only been
around since January it's been four
months and everything about this stinks
the company is called flow with a pH pH
L o W was created in January brand-new
company the CEO is dr. Eric Edwards will
talk about him in a minute he told The
Associated Press that Flo's mission is
to make the American drug supply chain
less reliant on other countries that's
something Trump's been talking about a
lot bringing our supply chains home in
the context of coronavirus we don't know
much about the company since it's only
been around for four months but we do
know a little something about their CEO
because dr. Eric Edwards previously had
a company with his twin brother called
Cali oh they increased the price of an
opioid antidote by six hundred percent
over three years at a cost to taxpayers
of a hundred and forty two million
dollars they tried to get some positive
PR by donating a bunch of doses to first
responders and then we heard from
several law enforcement agencies that
the doses they got from this company
Caleo were sometimes as little as four
months from expiring nice nice right
they also charged forty five hundred
dollars for their rival to the EpiPen
which was really more of an insurance
scam it was the idea was get insurance
companies paying them these outrageous
reimbursements for their competitor to
the EpiPen and of course what that leads
to is that people's insurance premiums
end up having to go up the idea that hey
the insurance company is paying so we
don't have to worry about it well then
everybody's premiums go up to account
for what they expect to be paying for
that and other medications of course
nothing illegal as far as we know this
is unfortunately this type of type of
stuff that's terrifically legal under
system so what's the connection why is
this company getting such a great deal
from the Trump administration well what
we know so far is that Trump's wacky
economic adviser Peter Navarro admitted
he bonded with a board member of this
company flow over get this skepticism
about China seems like China's
skepticism can be very very profitable
for this for people associated with this
administration so what exactly is this
company going to be doing for their
three hundred and fifty-four million
dollars they aim to manufacture some of
the raw ingredients for drugs in the
United States that would be needed to
treat coronavirus patients we don't
exactly know what that means the
contract is initially for three hundred
and fifty four million dollars over four
years it could be extended to a ten-year
deal for eight hundred and twelve
million dollars this would be one of the
largest amounts of money ever awarded to
a company in this type of arrangement
now you may not be surprised that the
flow website has a lot of the same sort
of America first style rhetoric and
language that Trump often bandies about
so in a week we might hear about some
further connection to the Trump family
wouldn't be surprising it'll barely get
attention it'll be another one of these
crony moves that Donald Trump promised
to stop this is a classic cash grab and
you see this a lot in more corrupt
countries or countries that are more
corrupt in this particular way the u.s.
is corrupted in sort of different ways
often you have a crisis and all sorts of
brand-new companies will be set up very
few employees very few questions about
whether they really do anything and they
get these massive lucrative contracts
this specific case with this company
flow it may or may not be an out-and-out
scam most likely the company is going to
do something but there could be shell
companies involved these are often
techniques to hide foreign interests or
other nefarious interests you can use
these to funnel money around and in a
lot of different ways it's the type of
stuffed Trump loves and in the end it's
our tax money it's our tax money during
times of crisis that gets funneled to
people that are making so much money
while 25% of the workforce has lost
their jobs this is what 63 million
people voted for either knowingly or
unknowingly I was reminded when I was
researching this story about the
whitefish fiasco
during the puerto rican hurricane
recovery although to call it a recovery
is probably probably a bit of an
exaggeration there was this company
whitefish energy based in montana two
full-time employees they concocted an
online presence with a hundred online
positive reviews they did it all within
72 hours of getting a 300 million dollar
contract from the Trump administration
the Trump interior secretary at the time
Ryan's Enki happened to be from the same
town as this company people associated
with the company happened to be big
investors big investors talk about a
Freudian slip donors to Donald Trump it
was a total swamp job and eventually
Puerto Rico canceled the contract and
now we are indeed seeing much of the
same around coronavirus a lot of money
being made with coronavirus that's for
sure this next story is not the most
important story but it's the epitome of
the petulant child that is the President
of the United States there's this
tradition and you know I don't care
about tradition for the sake of
tradition there's a tradition where for
the last 40 years presidents will come
back to the White House during the next
administration and their portrait will
be unveiled by the then president NBC
News is now reporting that Donald Trump
is refusing to do this for Barack Obama
and I have to tell you it kind of makes
sense
Donald Trump has spent the last couple
of weeks accusing Barack Obama of
committing the greatest political crime
in the history of the United States he's
dubbed it Obama gate it's totally bogus
it's non-existent but when you accuse a
former president of a crime
you're probably not also going to then
invite them to the White House to unveil
a painting of them now I don't care at
all about formalities I don't care about
faux bipartisanship but this is one of
the
things where you just expect presidents
will act in a certain way here is Barack
Obama welcoming George W Bush to the
White House for his portrait unveiling
and I'm not normalizing Bush I'm not
rehabilitating Bush Bush the Iraq war
was a disaster but they were able to be
in the same room with each other Obama
and Bush similarly here's George W Bush
welcoming Bill Clinton back to the White
House for the unveiling of his portrait
and again I don't care about these
ceremonies in a concrete sense
I recognize the signal it sends that
listen Republicans and Democrats this is
about elites versus the non elites it's
about neo liberals and non neoliberal
look I get it I understand that this is
not about ceremony because Trump is not
saying let's do away with this pointless
waste of time we're in a time of crisis
a party about a portrait is in bad taste
that's not what Trump is doing if he
were doing that I might actually respect
him for doing it Trump just hates Obama
Trump is threatened by Obama Trump has
spent much of his presidency trying to
either undo everything Barack Obama did
or take credit for the things Obama did
that he likes and wants to be praised
for and he has publicly accused Barack
Obama of being a criminal so this is a
farce this is not about breaking with
tradition
it's about being a global laughingstock
this is about Trump being the ultimate
trigger Abal snowflake while he pretends
to be the ultimate alpha male and this
is also about hypocrisy because
Republicans have claimed for decades
they are all about tradition they are
about doing the things the way that we
used to do them they are about returning
to this vaguely described prior way of
life that they love whether it's about
norms and conventions and tone or all of
this other BS it does very little to
help people who are struggling to feed
their families there's no doubt but
here's just a stupid opportunity to do
it just do the tradition do the tone
that you claim to love but no instead
Trump is publicly accusing Barack Obama
of the worst political crime in the
history of the United States despite
being unable to actually name what that
crime is because there was no such crime
and he is not going to do this totally
triggered snow flake pathetic
embarrassing the world can
used to laugh and this is what we've got
for four more years unless we all do
what we need to do in November let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman we will take a quick break
remember Monday Memorial Day one day
membership special huge membership
special beautiful membership special
historic membership special get on my
newsletter at david pakman.com you'll
get an email from me on monday with
instructions on how to take advantage of
this one-day discount the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are jeffrey kelly
and michael of points also want to say
thanks to joshua McGrew who is today's
longtime sustaining member of the day
Joshua's been with us for almost 5 years
grab a membership at join pakman.com
takes under one minute is really really
cheap you get great membership perks and
it feels good to do it it feels good to
do it let's go right to the phones at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we are going to start
today with our caller from the 4 8 0
area code who's calling today from 4 8 0
hi David is me yes it is what's your
name hi my name is Joseph Hey Joe what's
up hey so I've been a big fan I first
heard about you on Joe Rogan and just
had a quick question
so there doesn't appear to be any
official or constitutional mandate that
the incumbent president is required to
hold a debate with the opposing party's
nominee right Trump seems to gravitate
toward controversy and undermining our
institutions and we're seeing in real
time how he's trying to propagate
conspiracy theories about the
obama-biden administration yep how
likely is it that as a strategy to
undercut by the Trump forgoes debating
Biden altogether listen he's hinted at
he can do as many debates as he wants or
none at all and it shouldn't be up to
the Commission on
presidential debates to decide that that
sort of been his thing like that he says
he and the opponent whoever at the time
we didn't know who it was going to be
should just be able to sort it out and
do whatever they want but that the
Commission on Presidential Debates
shouldn't get to intervene I think
there's only about a 15% chance this is
just me pulling a number that Trump just
refuses to debate altogether I don't see
it as particularly likely especially
because I think Trump sees himself as
winning the debates for sure and so I
have a hard time imagining he'll really
go through with just not doing the
debates but it's not completely outside
the realm of possibility got it okay if
you don't mind and I just thought maybe
another question do you think that with
the lack of the campaign rallies because
of the pandemic right now that it's
going to hurt
Joe's chances of winning over voters not
on balance I mean listen the polls only
give us a snapshot of what's going on
right now
Trump's been failing on coronavirus and
Biden's just been doing interviews from
his house and Biden right now is doing
fine in the polls I think that the the
risk the Joe Biden is if Trump starts
doing rallies again particularly in
battleground states and Joe Biden
because the public health officials say
that this is probably not a good idea
Joe Biden abides by it that's where you
could see it start to hurt Joe Biden but
right now I don't think it's hurt him
and I don't think we can really find
data that suggests that it has so much
all right appreciate the call thank you
let's go next to our friend Dante from
Florida Dante from Florida what's what
do you have for me today Dante hey being
is actually dontel dontel supporter okay
I i we always had you as Dante and I
stand corrected on tell we will update
it in the system all right so there's a
lot of group thing around what the left
should do going forward and I want to
talk about that for a little bit
so like in the twenty20 much in the
there's this idea that people who agree
with Bernie Sanders platform is quality
platform that the best option that they
have to see those things implemented
would be to support your Biden and I
just don't think that's true I don't
give any evidences for that's true the
best way to see those policies
implemented would be to organize and try
to pressure congressional leadership and
pressure Donald Trump into implementing
so second dontel I want to make sure I
understand and try to keep the phone a
little further from your mouth because
you're coming in very hot and we're
having a hard time modulating you so it
sounds like you're sort of setting up a
let me fight let me inquire are you
setting up a false choice or are you
actually saying that Trump as president
and pressuring him will be better than
Biden being president are you actually
saying it would be better for Trump to
be president and to pressure Trump
rather than for Biden to be president
and to pressure Biden that you're not
going to push Joe Biden to the left
you're not gonna push him to the left to
the point where you get medicare-for-all
and the same with Donald Trump going
where you're gonna get medicare-for-all
is to force their hand to pressure them
with protests and calling them out the
Democratic leadership there are other
ways to do it on like how the sunrise
movement they organized that sit-in okay
but one second Don tell let me make sure
because the the first assertion you made
unless I misunderstood was rather your
you disagree that electing Joe Biden is
the way to get progressive stuff done
you said that congressional leaders
should pressure Trump but then you said
neither Joe hold on a second down to a
little bit hold on hold on it we're not
we're not gonna be able to talk unless
you I have to be able to tell you what I
heard and then you can correct it okay
okay
okay you first said you disagree with
what you called groupthink on the left
that Joe Biden is the best way to get
Bernie Sanders policies past you then
said I believe we are better off having
congressional leaders pressure Trump I
then asked are you saying you would
rather Trump than Biden because you
think we can get more from Trump you
then said no what I'm saying is either
way we're not getting Medicare for all
so how is it that we're going to if
either way we're not getting Medicare
for all how will we get it by pressuring
Trump to give it to us I didn't see
either way we're not getting Medicare
for all Joe Biden to the left we're not
going to push you know you can go back
and listen to it you said specifically
we're not going to push bot Biden to the
left to support order oh yes right said
you aren't we aren't going to be able to
get either of them to do it but you open
it up to the left all right a
conversation like this Dante I'm sorry
call back a different day and we'll try
to start up again go listen to the call
and you'll see exactly what you said
let's go next to our caller from the
five-seven four area code who's calling
today from 574 hi Brittany hey Brittany
what's up I was just wondering you have
any advice for someone whose family is
completely pro Trump
personally I'm not and all of my family
is and they're more on the abusive side
of the crow Truckers Oh what do you mean
by that who are they abusing well me if
I say or do anything they come at me and
act like I'm the bad child and I'm doing
all the wrong things and supporting the
wrong things and all that oh my goodness
what state what state is this all
happening in Buddha judge country
Indiana okay and so your entire family
is very much pro Trump and then you'll
introduce an alternative to that so to
speak and they will attack you yes in
even if it's like
site extremely way more logical like the
illogical miss comes out and then that's
when the abusive wordage and such comes
out can you give me an example of how
their how their verbally abusing you oh
basically you know this you know like
well you're stupid you don't you don't
know what you're talking about
it's it's all long lines of you know you
don't follow the family you're not
Christian enough oh my god yeah is this
evangelical Christianity yeah kind of
like I like to refer them as the Bible
beaters not so much of the going to
church but they promote that and if you
don't go you're a bad person and when
this happens is this like parents is it
siblings cousins what like generation
relative to you is it parents mostly Wow
wow that's tough I mean listen it
ultimately the answer is really in you
in the sense of what do you want your
relationship to look like with these
family members right because I I could
give you advice that would smooth things
over but to make you feel like you're
repressing your thoughts which isn't
good I could give you advice that would
be very confrontational where you would
feel like you're getting your thoughts
out but it could ruin your relationship
with your parents so really you know I
I'm not well-positioned to tell you what
how to handle it it's really about
figuring out what is it that you want
this relationship to look like because
you know I mean at a certain point
you've got a you may have to choose do I
want a reasonable superficially
reasonable relationship with my parents
where deep down you're extremely
frustrated or do you want to risk them
potentially shunning you it almost
sounds like in order to get your points
across and nobody can answer that other
than you Brittany yep I agree sorry to
hear about the situation I mean it
really sounds horrible it's not fun but
you know I appreciate your show it gives
me smiles and makes me feel better so
thank you thanks Brittany really great
to hear from you and
let us let us know how that all how that
all shakes out that's not not a good
situation whatsoever let's go - okay I'm
gonna oh is on the phone I think I
remember the pronunciate pronunciation
here ilysm Akua Okafor is joining us
from the five one three did I get that
right
wrong it's only somebody while ELISA
medulla okay
alright next time I'm gonna do it good
what's going on oh yeah Michigan and
Nevada and I mean I have to be honest
like that kind of scares the crap out of
me that you know the president's you
know thinking about you know extorting
states I mean I think one of the judges
who were in impeachment trials he
literally had an example of the bridge
and you know this is just like another
example of club you know just exploiting
I mean wearing a middle of a global
pandemic and I think I just wonder how
you know not just like the tweets itself
but like how well like is you know I
guess animosity towards absentee ballot
voting like will it you know be a thing
like well he's thought like limiting
people from voting yes so just just so
people know that this what Trump tweeted
was Michigan sends absentee ballots to
seven point seven million people ahead
of primaries in general election this
was done illegally and without
authorization by a rogue Secretary of
State I will ask to hold up funding to
Michigan if they want to go down this
voter fraud path this is this is a
totalitarian nightmare potentially
that's shaping up here because remember
Trump always talks about federalism the
power of the states all of the stuff
states are totally within their light
right to decide how they want to run
their elections and in fact the
presidential election is not a national
election it's 50 state elections and if
States want to do vote by mail they can
do it they're allowed to do that so when
Trump says I don't like it and I might
not give the money
this is exactly
the type of constitutional crisis that
unless we really are sure that we can
trust in our systems of checks and
balances which we can't be sure of right
now Trump could actually get away with
and it could be absolutely destructive
it's horrifying what he's doing what
he's saying anyway no no I mean listen I
don't want it I'm not you all know I'm
not alarmist but so so like for example
Trump if he loses in November will
probably say it was rigged but he is
going to leave like he's not gonna
physically resist you know it so I want
to be reasonable with people the stuff
Trump is now threatening on the
vote-by-mail is is genuinely scary and
then I do have another question I don't
know about this but there was news about
a cyber criminal group that allegedly
like hacked Trump's law firm in New York
and they said that they had bad things
honestly I think that it was like a load
of BS but apparently somebody like got a
hold of somebody like paid the ransom
hackers the money to like get a hold of
the data but I mean I don't know who so
I was wondering if you know you could
share some thoughts on that story I
actually I don't know anything about
that I haven't even heard of that okay
yeah okay I'll look into it all right
thank you I really appreciate the call
great to hear from you mm-hmm all right
take care well I'm sure hear from o
again next time I'll get his name right
let's go to our caller from the 7/7 for
area code 774 is risky it's often a
local caller and it's sometimes it goes
well sometimes it goes not so well
what's what's going on now I can barely
hear you my friend is there so I might
actually need you to speak up a little
bit David I'm here buddy but I'm telling
you that's blood on the streets
I'm trying to be careful I'm not trying
to be too loud okay David yes
okay listen Dave I am a socialist
I like social I like socializing or is
this pet producer cat friend again from
a different numbering are we not turning
into an T so okay that's the whole thing
oh you hung up okay I think that's Pat's
friend who just likes to make puns on
the term socialism it's really odd
okay let's try our caller from the 6:07
area code who's calling today from 6:07
hey yes I can you're coming in so loud
just pull the phone a little bit away
from your mouth and then I think we'll
be able to hear you much better
gotcha how's that my phone it's
marginally better but I would keep going
what's going on uh not much I asked you
a two questions at the can first one not
started make it short and sweet
I've only recently been becoming
politically literate to the like so you
know you and Kyle Kaminsky back in 2016
Tom hillary all that so these days you
need kind of research hormone all you
get is his you know his recent briefings
and press conferences so i was curious
if even if I could get your perspective
on why he seems to be so hated I'm from
upstate New York I wonder if it's a
second amendment thing or if there's
more that I have a research obviously
I'm still I have no idea why why rural
New York upstate errs would hate Andrew
Cuomo I mean I know that on the Left
there's a contingent that doesn't like
him because he's not really that
progressive I mean he's a pretty you
know he's a pretty centrist Democrat and
on fiscal issues in the state of New
York year he doesn't have any
particularly progressive records so I
think that I I couldn't tell you about
the gun people in upstate New York but
overall the left the left left isn't
thrilled with him because they feel that
the good press he's getting around
handling of coronavirus ignores the fact
that he has a very very centrist
moderate fiscal record in the state of
New York yeah absolutely that makes
sense I was also curious if you
also state your perspective on where you
think andrew Yang's future what might
hole to him I liked him initially you
know I don't get the bag that's
hilarious but he does have some other
policies I like and I do like the fact
that he's he's not a politician but now
I feel like he you know he's thinking
about running for for mayor I believe
and he's working for CNN and all that so
I was curious if you think that's gonna
gonna benefit him or maybe he should
maybe you should get that experience or
if he should continue trying to be I
have absolutely no advice whatsoever for
Andrew yeah I mean listen on the
popularity and following that he built
he probably would be able to find a
congressional seat to run for and have a
really good shot he could probably have
a shot you know maybe someday at a
Senate seat might require him you know
maybe maybe to move to a different state
potentially but he's built a following
that would allow him to raise money and
likely do very well for a number of
different positions but I I have no
advice and I have not heard anything
about his aspiration so I wouldn't be
able to say I'm gonna let you go because
that that that you're just so right on
your phone that it's crinkling and
crunching we're gonna take a quick break
if you are holding don't hang up because
I will be going right back to the
phone's momentarily the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him welcome back to the
David Pakman show let's go back to the
phones at six one seven eight three zero
four seven five zero and let's go to our
caller from the nine seven three area
code who's calling today from 973 hello
yes that's you and please keep the phone
a little further from your mouth you
you're just coming in so loud this
better
that's much better thank you okay hi I'm
remember I called last I called a couple
weeks ago but then the phone just the
phones aren't crashed and I never really
it you know I never got an answer to my
question okay the question I was asked
was for words I was curious as to like
why you know hypothetical scenario as to
why Bernie who did well in Michigan in
2016 for example lost Michigan
horrendously in 2020 and I said a theory
was one that George Orwell had just
described in his book the road to work
in fear where he said that although
everyone ought to be a socialist the
reason why working-class people turn
away from socialism is because it
attracts it attracts when he described
Craig's you know people who like we
described them as like you know sandal
wearing tweed you know that you can't
really describe them there's like
vegetarian nudists feminists in his own
words and I kind of wonder do you think
that like in 2020 the progressive
movement ignored world what Orwell's
warnings in the book and paid the
consequences of it
I'm not familiar with that Orwell quote
but listen if you look at any of my post
mortems on what happened to bernie there
is no question that the language of
revolution the not simply saying hey
listen guys i'm a social democrat not a
democratic socialist social democracy is
a regulated form of capitalism i don't
think that the the democratic socialist
label helped i think some of the people
around him didn't help so yeah i mean i
i it in i essentially completely agree
with what you're quoting to me from
george orwell and every post mortem I've
done of why Bernie lost and lost badly I
mean I know people say you know you
can't look at the vote totals now
because Bernie dropped out a little
while ago Biden was up by almost two
million votes while Bernie was still
fully running the campaign it was not a
small victory for Biden and I think all
the things you're alluding to via the
George Orwell quote are a hundred
percent in line with my analysis I'm
also curious what your thoughts are on
this failed invasion of Venezuela since
I I didn't hear anything of it unless he
mentioned it on the bonus show I don't
know much about it i I know that there
were some I don't even know what to call
the mercenaries I guess they would be
called and there were allegations that
they were associated somehow with the
Trump administration although every
every source for that was was sort of
different versions of propaganda state
media that were saying that so I don't
I'm still researching that I've not
taken a position one way or the other on
it I mean obviously I'm against any coup
in Venezuela that the US has involved in
to just get that on the record what I
mean is I don't know enough about that
situation to comment intelligently right
now okay okay
all right my friend thank you so much
for the call great to hear from you
let's see who else is on the phone at
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's try a caller this is
crazy now we're going to country code
ninety two I have no idea what this is
but let's go to country code ninety two
with me yes it is who's this where are
you calling from
oh hi dear my name is usman I'm guarding
from Pakistan how are you and please
just take the phone a little further
from your mouth so you come through a
little more clearly
is it better no yes thank you okay
I just wanted to say that I'm a very big
fan of you I've been watching you since
I was 14 years old amazing now yeah so I
really like her so you were like the
first progressive youtuber which I
started towards you and Kerensky this is
incredible though I'll ask you my friend
are in in Pakistan are American
progressive youtubers known at all like
are you able to go to someone in your
community and say hey did you see that
Kyle kolinsky clip and like someone else
would say oh yeah I did see that like
RDR these channels that all followed in
your country they're not you're the only
one you don't talk about politics much
with my friends okay so all although my
dad just progressed a progressive he
used to be a socialist doing his college
days so I talked about politics with
them you're gonna need to pull the phone
much further from your mouth because
you're coming through so distorted but I
would love to get a question from you if
you're able to just just keep pulling
that phone away from your mouth okay is
it better now
yes it is okay I just wanted to ask you
how how would you respond to the claims
that wage labor is slavery so you're a
social democrat yes I normally prefer so
should it see that beach beach label is
some form of exploiting of
very case so how would you respond to
that well already you've sort of you've
gone from saying wage labor is slavery
to wage labor is exploitation now those
are two very different scenarios I
completely reject the idea that wage
labor on principle is slavery however
there is no doubt that there is some
degree if we define exploitation as
someone who establishes the factory is
profiting from the labor of someone else
then that is a form of exploitation now
we might say that if the working
conditions are good if everybody has
good benefits and is paid a fair wage
that that surplus that the capitalists
to use Marxist language earns from the
the wage laborer that it is a fair
exchange for taking the risk of
establishing the factory and buying the
capital and the machines and
establishing human reach you know all of
this different stuff human resources etc
so slavery I would say absolutely that's
that's not you know of course we can
find situations where there is slavery
indentured servitude and I'm against
those the idea of exploitation we're now
talking about ok what is a fair amount
of profit for the capitalist in exchange
for creating the factory risking their
capital employing other people etc and
and then you're already talking about a
gray area if that makes sense and that
that area is where social democracy
essentially operates what is a fair
amount of profit for the capitalist and
what should they be required to provide
an exchange to ensure that people have a
living wage and a social safety net yes
my pleasure in America are there any
progresses of governance that that you
admire that share our ideas
that's progressives there's no one that
shares all of the ideas but you know
with so jay inslee is really good on
climate and you know you you can sort of
pick and choose from different governors
uh what what you like listen I so
appreciate your call from Pakistan tell
me again what your name was
Oh my name is usman a smart okay very
good
I I really appreciate your call and I
hope to hear from you again oh sure sure
I love this I mean by right bye-bye okay
great and as people can tell you've got
to keep the phone when people get right
up on the phone like that the phone
system just cannot handle it so keep
that I'll turn you up on my end keep
that phone away from your mouth let's go
next to our caller from the 7:04 area
code who's calling today from 704 yeah
that's you who's this my name is Durham
from Charlotte hey Jordan what's up I
just want to tell you I'm a huge fan i
watch it all the time
thank you um I just had it I just had a
quick question about merit voting about
sorry mayo mail-in voting yes
Marit Marit boding voting oh I'm sorry
yes go ahead yeah so I was just thinking
since you know we got Trump of course
that got me thinking that I don't think
that voting is so much of right it is a
privilege um so in that I would say I
would just like to ask you what your
thoughts of sort of a maybe like
something like a citizenship test but
not the citizenship test but something
just to show that you're knowledgeable
and that you're informed about who and
what you're voting for
yeah whether that be the room listen
well right I've taken versions of this
question dozens of times over the years
and I get the instinct I've taken it
also in terms of parenting like wouldn't
we be way better off if you had to pass
some test to be a parent and wouldn't we
be way better off if you had to pass
some basic tests in order to vote
I understand why why that instinct comes
up I really do but it just can't be done
it can't be done because you first of
all I don't believe that it would be
constitutional number one that that
because even though you consider voting
a privilege it is a right it is a right
that people have and it can only be
removed under very narrow circumstances
most of which I actually disagree with
so in practice anything like that any
kind of voting test or parenting test as
others have suggested it would end up
disproportionately impacting poor people
where part of the problem is they're
already lacking access to education so I
it would have disastrous unintended or
intended depending on who you are
consequences and I get the instinct I
don't think you're coming for it from a
bad place like how did 63 million people
get bamboozled into voting for Donald
Trump I get it but it would be very
problematic in its application yeah I
totally agree and I think that's why we
wouldn't need to fix other problems such
as health care education right call it
quits and etc it's tougher right like it
sounds easier to just put in place a
voting test rather than to deal with
those issues but but you you or you're
agreeing that those are the issues that
really we got to deal with yes of course
thank you for your insight appreciate
the call thank you so much let's see who
else wants to check in today why don't
we go to our caller from the 7:27 area
code who's calling today from 7 to 7 7
to 7 we can hear you we're on yeah we're
not on speaker are we we're not on
speaker we're on speaker gotcha nah not
anymore
all right what can I do for you today
[Music]
it's really real that's what I'm doing
we had again Tom other foot office in
holy
hopefully this is readable right I am
like no way okay
strong mob all the cons beer is in the
world smoke it all up because they crazy
dude right how do you know one good good
how are you family you well are you
talking to mirrors there another
conversation happening in the background
there are you high right now yeah gotcha
gotcha
alright well listen it's it's really
been a pleasure I so appreciate the
phone call it finally happened okay yeah
man I love you sure I'm glad I
discovered who you are in your program I
think you're awesome and you are
definitely in my daily routine now thank
you
ever and telescas over you know I
celebrate questioning I love you show me
I think you're totally awesome right on
dude about my PB even tell you answered
the waiver we think Trump won't wear
math right that was a good segment that
was a good segment alright my friend
thank you so much for the call I am
gonna let you go we are we are at a time
and Wow
today's calls I'm sweating my friends I
am sweating let's go to a break we will
take calls again sorry that I was not
able to get to everyone today
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
ok let's get into audience questions for
the week and some really good ones first
one is about these two special elections
in California and Wisconsin the question
is hey David do California and Wisconsin
special elections going to Republicans
mean an inevitable disaster for
Democrats in November of 2020 the answer
is no the answer is no so if you've not
been following these two races you had
the 7th congressional district in
Wisconsin in the twenty fifth
Congressional District in California two
special elections both went to the
Republican candidates Mike Garcia
defeating Christie Smith in California's
25th Wisconsin's seventh went to the
Republican candidate Tom Tiffany so
let's talk first about California and
then about Wisconsin but before we even
do that special elections tend to have
low turnout and in particular we know
that one party benefits from lower
turnout Republicans benefit from lower
turnout so you have to be very careful
about taking especially not just any
special election but in the case of
California's 25th the special election
in a historically red district at least
when it comes to members of Congress and
saying hey alert low turnout special
election went to the Republican this
spells trouble in the fall it could
there could be trouble in the fall for
Democrats and for Joe Biden in the 25th
but this is not evidence of it so let's
start with California 25th California
25th is this district that was held by
Democratic congresswoman Katie Hill
Katie hill ended up resigning she
resigned because she was involved in a
relationship with a staffer the nothing
illegal took place but it does violate
House Ethics guidelines and so she
resigned so a couple of things then went
on you had this jungle primary for the
November race simultaneously with the
special election primary you with the
special election you had a blowback
effect where this is you know they call
it a purple district but this was a seat
that was held for 25 years by Republican
buck McKeon and then for four years by
Republican Steve Knight they call it a
purple
district but it's been a Republican hell
district at the Congressional level for
a really really long time and then it
went to Katie Hill and Katie Hill had to
resign and there was a blowback effect
to some degree that has nothing to do
with what we would expect to see in the
fall so that's number one
Republicans are seeing the headline as
hey a Republican won a seat that was
just held by a Democrat this is great
for Republicans the real story is that
Katie Hill had taken the seat that had
been held by Republicans for a really
long time and it doesn't tell us that
Trump is going to start winning blue
states in 2020 then you get to
Wisconsin's seventh I actually think
that Wisconsin's seventh although it got
less attention than could the California
25th is more relevant for thinking about
2020 if you look at the results of the
Wisconsin's seventh special election
just recently and compare it to how
those areas voted in 2016 there was
really no major shift if you look at the
elements that make up the Wisconsin
seventh and you look at how did they
vote on Trump versus Hillary in 2016 and
how did they vote but for Tiffany versus
the Democratic challenger in that recent
special election you could say well
maybe I believe it's pronounced an Ida
or an ADA an ADA County that might be a
flip that came within twenty votes in
the judicial election that just took
place it's gonna be pretty similar to
2016
so Wisconsin's seventh is potentially
more consequential when thinking about
2020 because any small change in
Wisconsin could flip the state when you
look at California you can argue about
California's 25th as a sort of
guideposts for what might happen bigger
picture in California but Trump's not
gonna win California no matter what
right Katy Hill resigned she was a
Democrat now a Republican won been a
Republican state for decades before it
was Katy it doesn't matter because
Biden's going to win California in
Wisconsin even these small shifts the
margin was small enough in Wisconsin I
don't remember exactly what I think was
about 20
votes that is a state that if the wind
blows one way versus the other
if older voters abandoned Trump and go
to Biden the way we've been seeing you
could actually get a different result
where Donald Trump doesn't win Wisconsin
so I don't think either tells us what is
in store for November but if I were to
look at one of them as maybe being a
more impactful signal it would be
looking at Wisconsin's seventh not
California's 25th hey David when it
comes to coronavirus are we the only
country smearing doctors who are trying
to save lives like dr. Anthony foutch II
it's a good question
Anthony foul he has been smeared widely
by the coronavirus protesters who have
been saying for more than a month now
we've got to open it up we never should
have closed it down we saw a chance of
fire pouchy at a number of different
protests we more recently I covered this
earlier in the week we saw signs that
say hang foul Chi and hang Bill Gates as
well but the truth is that we are not
the only country where doctors have been
targeted the thing is in most of the
other places where we see it the doctors
are being targeted by the state not by
random protesters so I'll give you some
examples we know that early very early
in the corona virus outbreak in China
there were doctors who were starting to
see the spread of corona virus and they
were talking about it and we have a
number of reports that law enforcement
authorities showed up at the homes of
some of these Chinese doctors and said
you've got to stop talking about this
this is you you can't keep talking about
this spreading virus which at the time
we knew very little about and hadn't
really identified this was in late 2019
so certainly we've seen antagonism of
doctors in China the difference is it's
not coming from random protesters it's
not coming from media in the same way
maybe state media but we did see law
enforcement antagonized doctors in
Russia we have a number of reports of
doctors who were working on corona virus
and speaking about corona virus who fell
out of windows now I don't want to say
more than what we know
it sounds weird to me it's like those
stories of hey someone fell on a knife
ten times okay well what do you mean
they fell on a knife ten times there are
reports of multiple Russian doctors that
were making public statements about
coronavirus who fell out of windows and
died I'm not gonna say any more because
we don't know anymore but my point is I
am not aware of the loud public
campaigns against doctors who know about
infectious disease in other countries
but we do know I guess we could call it
hostility hostility towards the the
medical community from some state
governments and there's probably more
examples that I haven't mentioned but an
important question and I mean listen
auntie VAX exists in a lot of the world
there isn't you know when we started
seeing the the measles outbreaks as a
result of communities that didn't want
to vaccinate it wasn't just the United
States we have a lot of them in the
United States it wasn't just the United
States when we look at protests to
reopen it's not just the United States
we saw them in isolated spots around the
world but it's mostly in the United
States that we have this phenomenon and
I don't know you know we can make a lot
of broad claims about what it says about
society oh we have the most stupid
people we have the most ignorant
whatever we also have some of the
smartest people and a lot of them a lot
of them but there is something cultural
here where these ideas get a life of
their own media will often give them
oxygen and it's definitely very very bad
here no question about it David if
Donald Trump is unfortunately reelected
in November of 2020 how bad do you think
his second term would be so in thinking
about a Trump second term there are two
sides to it
one is Trump is incredibly childish and
vindictive the other side is Trump is
incredibly lazy so I would predict that
a second term Trump would simultaneously
be more unhinged and brazen and
authoritarian and going after his
political enemies using executive
orders to do whatever he wants more
frequently but at the same time I see
him watching a lot more TV and playing a
lot more golf and being even lazier than
he has been because he's not gonna have
anything else to campaign for maybe
towards the end of his second term Trump
would have a Republican nominee to
campaign for if they believe that it
would be useful remember back in 2008
you didn't see george w bush campaigning
for john mccain very much because george
w bush's approval rating was in the
toilet and it wouldn't have been a good
thing for mccain to have bush out there
prominently so i would expect a few
different things trump's not gonna have
his rally so he'll watch more TV and
play more golf he'll feed his ego on
twitter in terms of what he will get
done
certainly donald trump will continue to
get a lot done on judges because trump
is just the tool in mitch mcconnell's
toolbox so to speak when it comes to
judges and they will continue they may
get more Supreme Court justices on the
court depending on who goes and who
stays in Trump second term they will
keep putting more federal judges in and
so no doubt if Trump is given four more
years laziness aside tweeting aside his
effect on the Jewish judiciary is going
to be absolutely damaging for decades to
come that's going to continue beyond
that I don't believe you will see Trump
do much of significance when it comes to
big policy achievements I don't think
Trump will get anything done on
healthcare the way he promised to do
during his first term and a lot of the
reason is Trump doesn't really believe
in what he's doing you know Trump put
together this faux conservative ideology
where he pretended to care about debt
and he pretended to care about you know
stopping abortion and stuff he didn't
care about his entire life and Trump's
ideology is not a conservative ideology
it's what I call and sort of imbecilic
reactionary ideology where Trump just is
very opinionated and in some cases he is
very reactionary in other cases he's
libertarian in the sense that he doesn't
care what people do he's taking
positions on some of these issues
because he's figured out that it appeals
to evangelical and other right-wing
voters so because Donald Trump doesn't
really have
a very important or significant
political ideology as such I think Trump
will not get much done at all and he's
just gonna kind of hang out now his
authoritarianism combined with his
vindictive nature to me suggests that in
addition to helping Mitch McConnell get
his judges in maybe trying to you know
get some kind of tax cuts done and
putting continuing to tweet and watch TV
there is a very good chance that Donald
Trump is going to really start taking
his anger out even more on media people
that he doesn't like on politicians that
he feels haven't been supportive enough
of him so I would expect a second term
Trump will really try to ruin people's
lives his enemies lives the people that
he perceives as his Emma not having been
with him while he mostly just rubber
stamps whatever Republicans convinced
him to do it will be very very ugly it
will be very ugly and it is of course no
I don't want to say renewed importance
because it's been of constant importance
that we do everything we can to remove
this guy in November please don't forget
that Monday Memorial Day we have a
one-day David Pakman show membership
explosion planned it's been months since
we did any of these big membership
specials Monday everybody on our mailing
list will get an email the email will
say a lot of good things about you it
will say you're a beautiful person
you're a tremendous a tremendously good
person for being on our mailing list and
watching the show listen oh you know
will sing your praises
but then here's the key part the email
that goes out on Memorial Day will tell
you how to get a disgustingly I mean
this is it's a vilely you've it's a vile
huge discount off of membership and
it'll be a one-day special okay get on
the mailing list at david pakman.com top
right of the website you type in your
email address you'll be on the mailing
list Monday you'll get an email with
this membership special and you will
also as a member get access [ __ ] bonus
show which today is hosted by producer
he will talk to you on the bonus show
momentarily I will be back with you
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]